on November 30th of 2022 the world
changed forever artificial intelligence
or AI became accessible to the public
for free through a tool called chat gbt
chat GPT which stands for generative
pre-trained Transformer a robot you can
talk to you can log on to and have a
conversation with and it went from zero
to a million users in five days which is
the fastest any platform has gone to a
million users it took Facebook two years
took Instagram two years took Pinterest
four months and it took Angry Birds 35
days
I think that it has the potential to
unravel the very fabric of capitalism
itself and what it means for us as
individuals and a little bit later in
the video I'm going to tell you how you
can capitalize on this to 10x how much
you make rather than being afraid of it
in the short term and curling up in a
ball and putting your head in the sand
and like hoping it goes away it's here
and it's only going to get more
dangerous and Powerful so there's five
major areas that I think it's going to
completely turn on its head number one
is the nature of work itself the second
is how businesses operate the third is
the economy overall the fourth is how we
interrelate with one another on a
romantic setting how we choose mates how
we seduce how we have sex all of that
stuff and finally the nature of life
itself and how it actually extends to
interplanetary life and whether or not
aliens exist here on Earth I'm not a big
woo tin hack guy but I think if you
actually think through the logic there's
some really alarming conclusions that
you can come to
AI is going to be the biggest shift in
our lifetime it is the equivalent in my
opinion of the moon landing except the
only difference is that it will actually
change all of our Lives rather than just
being a picture to say that we won the
Cold War different than the internet
phone systems television because what
those did was they reshuffled the
workforce this has the ability to remove
or eliminate the workforce altogether
cryptocurrencies in general had the
potential to overturn the financial
institution AI is the potential to
overturn the Human Institution I try to
convince people to slow down
slow down AI to regulate AI
I tried for years
you don't know who I am or you're new to
the channel my name is Alex tremozzi I'm
the founder of acquisition.com we're a
portfolio of companies that does over
200 million a year and I make these
videos so that you can use them and make
lots and lots of money and hopefully you
become a company between three and 100
million dollars and we can invest in
your business and help you scale beyond
that so in order for us to productively
talk about AI to understand what the
terms we're actually talking about are
AI is a type of technology that helps
machines or computers do things that
normally need a human brain to do stuff
like learning solving problems making
decisions and understanding what we see
or hear the thing that made the release
on November 30 is so wild is that chat
GPT democratized access to AI for the
first time because it had an interface
that we could all use chat they created
a massive language model that allowed it
to understand our prompts and queries
and be able to translate that into
machine speak get the answer and then
re-translate it back to us in human
speak that is what made it so powerful
because now all of us can use it right
now chatgpt spits out words sentences
paragraphs articles and even entire
books it can write legal documents it
can write sales scripts and write video
scripts the list is literally endless I
asked it the other day to write a cold
email to a plumbing company for
marketing SEO services and it spit it
out and then I said cool make it funnier
and shorter spit out another version and
I said great turn it into a text message
did it turn it into a tweet store did it
it's difficult to comprehend the extent
of it because it's only really limited
by our ability to ask the right
questions which I'll get to later
because it's going to be very important
in terms of how you choose to use AI
That's Just Words as the output but we
understand other things we can interpret
images we can interpret videos and we
can interpret sounds and the crazy thing
is is that AI can do that too so openai
also runs Dali which is an image engine
generator and so if I said hey give me a
guy smoking a cigar looking over a beach
where there's a dragon
now make it in Van Gogh painting style
crazy now make me 10 versions of that
now if you think about the nature of
what a video is back in the day was used
to be a flip book they would take images
and they would flip the pictures and
then you'd have a video because we can't
tell the difference at past a certain
speed and so if it can make images then
if it makes lots of images in a row it
can make videos but on top of that if it
has the words and it can make the video
it can also make the Sounds in the very
near future those will merge and the
same degree the inputs being text or
verbal will also merge this is the
reason Elon Musk has been such a big
proponent of neuralink he wants to take
it a factor further rather than be
limited by our ability to speak or
ability to type he wants it to be
limited by our ability to think now that
may sound like science fiction but it's
already here many of us were alive
during the first iPhone launch now we're
on iPhone 14 or 15 or whatever it's on
now what we see today is our first
version that we can see chat GPT 100 is
going to be significantly more advanced
and will be able to input an output on
demand any of these things the way we
want them the next important Milestone
is when AI actually enters the physical
world Elon revealed that Tesla bot the
thing is is that that's what it is today
again like the iPhone in many machine
Generations which happen faster than
human Generations that will be able to
look exactly like a human and it will
definitely if you look at Boston
Dynamics there's robots that actually
function better than humans that have
longer arms and are much stronger and
can jump and don't need to sleep it
won't have sexual complaints blah blah
blah once those machine Generations
happen on Robotics and on the AI side
we'll reach a point where they're super
intelligence and super intelligence is
defined as where the AI itself is
smarter than all humans put together I
think it takes like unique human
arrogance to believe that uh AI cannot
supersede humans at that point the world
will change significantly this is where
access to the super intelligence will
become the most valuable resource on
planet Earth for example if I were to
say hey build me a trillion dollar
company it could in real time write the
code for the product write the scripts
for the ads generate the videos for the
ads directly interface with the media
buying place the ads where it already
knows where the targeted audience is
push those targeted audiences eyes to
landing pages that it had built with
scripts and videos that it had built and
then transact all from a single prompt
who determines who gets the access will
be a really important question for the
future the second is what will govern
the types of prompts and queries that we
can ask it so if we said how do I wipe
out the entire human race for less than
a hundred thousand dollars we don't want
it really answering questions like that
there's going to have to be some
regulation around this because the thing
is that's a lot of power if we had a
thousand times the rate of innovation it
would be the same as having all
Innovations between the Period of
Enlightenment and today happen next year
and so that gives away the last step in
the AI Evolution which is the
singularity The Singularity is a
hypothetical Future Point in which
technological progress and artificial
intelligence will advance to the point
where Humanity will undergo a
transformation Beyond which it cannot be
seen the first truly intelligent machine
will be the last invention that Humanity
needs to make many people postulate that
that's the point where it will become
either self-aware it will start my make
its own decisions and ignore us well it
won't really want to kill us because it
has no reason to for the same reason
that we don't want to kill ants but if
we build a highway we destroy some ant
hills so it's just gonna do what it's
going to do some robots will eat some
jobs and some robots will kill humans
you've already seen that with
self-driving cars but when you look at
the trend as a whole I think it's going
to be incredibly positive for Humanity
this is why Elon and Sam Altman and
those guys are trying to align our goals
of humanity with the goals of the AI
it's the only really productive thought
process we can have because we can sit
here and be afraid but I don't think
we're going to stop the technological
progress even if they banned it knowing
how the internet is and knowing how
black hat coders Etc are I have a hard
time believing that they will be able to
stop it because the thing is this will
be the equivalent of having the new
nuclear bomb of this Century or this
Millennia if Humanity collectivity
decides that creating digital super
intelligence is the right move
then
we should do so very very carefully this
is the most important thing that we
could possibly do
that's all Pie in the Sky stuff let's
talk about day to day let's talk about
business
so to frame this conversation I think
you have to watch this clip because it
will make everything about the same make
sense so this is from Google and this is
from four years ago their personal
assistant Ai and they haven't released
this to the public which is weird
you hi I'm
Kyle
mm-hmm
first name is Lisa
okay perfect so I will see Lisa at 10
o'clock on May 3rd okay great thanks
great have a great day bye that's the
Baseline that was four years ago now
imagine it was a sales call and we have
sales AI That's listened to 10 million
sales calls this is the types of things
that these people say in these
situations I will say the same thing and
then iterates and learns over and over
again the AI can live a million
lifetimes in terms of the amount of
volume it can churn through and process
and learn from compared to a human so
the best sales guy is going to have this
much experience compared to the best AI
sales guy and so if it can have those
calls 24 hours a day in real time to
whatever Prospect you want you may even
imagine a world where you ask the phone
teller hey are you a human and when they
say no I'm AI you're relieved because
you're like thank God I'm talking to the
best version of this who can handle my
problem right now so if you were to have
asked people what jobs do you think AI
will replace first most people said
first it'll replace the low skill jobs
the physical labor and then it'll be the
low skilled White Collar jobs and then
it'll be the high school White Collar
jobs like programmers and coders and
then finally maybe it'll replace the
creative jobs but what's interesting is
that it actually happened in the reverse
order if you're a copywriter this has
serious implications for you a logo
designer this has serious implications
for you customer service 24 hours a day
in real time immediate feedback what
happens to all the Physicians it becomes
immediate and more accurate for us to
have access to a medical AI from our
homes and it can see us because it can
interpret their data visually too if
you're in finance it will be able to
take all of the raw data and realign it
and put it into beautiful Excel sheets A
friend of mine has a father who's a
medical malpractice attorney he asked it
to write an argument for why malpractice
should not be capped in terms of how
much a lawyer can make on a malpractice
suit and then outlined an entire
argument for why it should be uncapped
it happened to be almost identical to
the argument that he had after 40 years
of experience you see videos like this
you see all these people on YouTube you
see Instagram posts well what if the AI
reads every single Instagram post of all
time and ranks them by highest
performing and then merge that with
video and defects we will have pundits
and influencers that don't exist imagine
you could create the perfect celebrity
or the perfect spokesperson or the
perfect porn star and with deep fakes
they can work 24 hours a day say exactly
what you want and what they say has the
perfect tone and me to just stimulate
the [ __ ] out of our dopamine centers and
we're just going to be plugged in
because it knows what we like better
than we do if you don't believe me go to
this person does not exist.com and just
keep refreshing it and it will show you
new people now if you remember earlier a
video is made of multiple images put
together back to back to back if it can
make an image of a real person it can
make many images of real people if they
can make many images of real people it
can make a video of a real person and
then we'll have questions of
verification did President Biden say
that did President Trump say that or is
it a deep fake the blue check mark will
take on an entirely new meaning in the
very near future now those are just a
few a few use cases but anywhere humans
are it will disrupt if you are connected
to the AI you can input faster and you
can get information back faster because
you're not limited by your digits this
will be the next order of magnitude in
terms of output and value that
individuals be able to create in the
economy
I do think that there's a chance that
capitalism as a system for society may
be overturned you're gonna have a huge
cost basis that's going to be eliminated
so things make it cheaper but at the
same time the money that would have gone
to those people that's going to go into
the economy won't be there the point is
is that I think there will be
significant changes in capitalism
overall now one of the nice things Sam
Altman who's the CEO they have actually
been undergoing the largest Ubi study so
Universal basic income study as a result
concurrently with this technology so he
knows what they're making we're going to
have an opportunity to push the reset
button and think about the world we want
and I think Universal basic income is
one part of that he knows the impact of
what's going to have now in the short
term we'll be able to harness this and
this is what I think we'll Foster in at
least in the short term a golden age for
Humanity in terms of what we're going to
be able to accomplish scientifically I
believe that we will be able to achieve
nuclear fusion fusion is renewable clean
energy for everyone when you reconstruct
the energy infrastructure upon which all
of society is laid upon it changes
everything and so in a very real way
this will be a more significant change
or revolution in humanity in my opinion
than the Industrial Revolution which
changed everything but let's talk about
a very different topic let's talk about
romance this is where in my opinion it
gets a little bit scary the bottom tier
of society have a harder time getting
mates girls or guys imagine if we've
studied a million Tinder conversations
to get the first date there'll be tools
probably called first date AI that can
AI from first convo all the way to the
date getting set so let's take it a step
further we have the phone version of
this and you can hear a voice that has
been tuned to your preferences of the
exact type of voice that you want to
hear that talks to you and listens to
you like the kind heart that they are
and they don't care that you talk too
much and you only talk about yourself
and when you say these weird things they
just let it go because we think we're
more complicated than they are but we
really just have inputs that our brain
interprets from an electrical signal and
then assigns meaning to and once you
know the inputs you just hit the buttons
and that's what it will learn how to do
now we fall in love with robots take it
a step further the Tesla bot five
generations 10 Generations from now
looks like a human and now has that in
the brain what happens when the robot
humans are more attractive more loving
more caring more considerate and cheaper
than a spouse
before I explain how you can maximally
use this to make the most money and live
the best life in the short term based on
the skills that we have today indulge me
for one more moment because I think it's
really profound and I think it's going
to change the way you see the world
let's talk about aliens oh
we'll have talked about alien technology
and like what if there was a UFO that
was captured all that kind of stuff so
let's put a pin in that play this out
with me when humans want to explore the
universe what do we send first we send
Mars Rover we send a robot right right
if aliens are further ahead of us then
it means that they probably have ai if
they're going to send something they
would probably send a robot why because
a robot doesn't need to eat it can live
for a very long time and it can survive
in harsher different climates than
biology can on top of that it can work
on itself whereas biology cannot so
aliens might be here but not necessarily
in their physical form in their AI form
because if we can create robots that
perfectly clone humans so can they and
that may be who they sent or what they
sent to check out what we're doing AI
would be the perfect thing to send to
another planet because up to this point
when we send something it takes five
years for it to reach whatever Planet
it's on and so by the time it's there
it's really old technology and so it
makes sense that you'd want to send
something that is completely adaptable
and can rewrite its own code space
exploration may be done by AI more than
it is done by humans because this stuff
our flesh we're super easy to kill but
the AI can live super cold super hot no
oxygen lots of oxygen it's good and once
we saw fusion with it it won't even need
the sun which leads to one question
about life itself if we Define death as
the inability to receive inputs so like
when you die you can't receive inputs
anymore and we Define personality as the
conglomerate of our actions and
behaviors as a result of our past
experiences then if I were to upload my
thoughts and behaviors and past
experiences how I talk how I speak I
think Etc into a cloud drive and then it
were able to pass the Turing test
everybody I know couldn't tell whether
it was me or robot version of me then is
it me and if that thing can now go
travel planets is it humans that are
traveling to planets or is it an AI
cyborg version of humans I don't know
interesting questions and you're like
okay Alex you took me to romance robot
wives and Aliens how do I make more
money today so the first first thing
that I would ask is that you adopt the
mentality that AI isn't here to replace
me it's here to supercharge me why do I
say that because if you adopt the other
one you might as well just throw in the
towel now you have to embrace change
it's part of humanity technology moves
we got to adapt if AI can condense our
inputs so if I say hey go read this book
distill it down and then give it to me I
can now read a book significantly faster
if I say hey ai go summarize all my
email and all my slack messages and
predict what I'm going to say and then
all I need to do is validate it I can do
a days worth of work in a few minutes I
think of chat EBT and AI of the future
as a filter through which we will
perceive the world both in and out think
of it as your home screen you read
everything through AI because it has
already distilled it down to the most
important nuggets for you then in the
output side it makes predictions on what
you would say normally and it continues
to get training it better and then it
sends it we can consume 10 times the
information and produce 10 times the
output which is 100x increase so that's
level one the next level is the expert
level and these are the people who are
losing sleep over being like Oh my my
God this thing can now do my job if
you're an expert what used to take you
90 of your time which is generating
things you now expand most of your time
to using the machine to generate and
then you spend your time doing QA and
validating the information making tweaks
it's in a very real way using these
tools you become more valuable to the
companies that you work for or the
clients that you serve I'll leave you
with this this video was made entirely
by Ai and this is a deep fake
I'm just kidding but someday it might be